je propose que nous continuions nos
auditions et pardonnez-nous du léger
retard mais ça s'enchaîne
et voilà on a du mal à
complètement être dans le dans le cadre
mais on n'a pas non plus dérapé
complètement donc mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons aujourd'hui nos
auditions de la journée en recevant
Monsieur Nicolas Dufour directeur
général de BPI France
madame Sophie Raymond qui est directrice
de l'expertise et Monsieur Jean-Baptiste
marin lamellée
directeur des relations
institutionnelles
BPI France est une société je garde
est une société anonyme dont le capital
est détenu à parité par l'État et la
case des dépôts est consignation
des pays France et la banque publique
d'investissement français chargée de
soutenir le développement des
entreprises via de nombreux outils de
financement et d'accompagnement elle
joue notamment un rôle important dans le
financement de l'innovation de l'export
et dans le soutien à la modernisation de
l'industrie si son action couvre tous
les secteurs de l'économie ne nous
intéresserons aujourd'hui bien sûr à
l'industrie pharmaceutique et en
particulier à la production de
médicaments avec la prise de conscience
consécutive à la pandémie de covid 19 la
réindustrialisation voir la
relocalisation du médicament bénéficie
d'un véritable regain d'intérêt dans les
politiques publiques nous parlons
à longueur de temps quasiment de
souveraineté dans ce secteur où les
investissements sont lourds et risqués
vous nous direz si cet engouement récent
se traduit aujourd'hui par des
possibilités
suffisantes de financement privé pour le
développement de capacités européennes
de production de médicaments notamment
mature ou si à l'inverse l'intervention
du secteur public et de votre banque
reste nécessaire pour soutenir une vraie
dynamique vous pourrez à ce titre nous
préciser le rôle que vous avez joué dans
la mise en oeuvre des appels à projets
relatifs à la relocalisation en lien
avec le DGE que nous avons déjà
auditionné quel est votre regard sur la
viabilité de ces projets industriels et
leurs besoins de financement
BPI France sera aussi amené à intervenir
dans le déploiement du plan innovation
santé 2030 est amené d'ailleurs à
intervenir dans le plan
innovation santé 2030 que nous évoquons
tout à l'heure plus en détail avec
l'agence pour l'innovation en santé vous
pourrez nous donner votre analyse de
l'écosystème l'innovation en santé en
France puisqu'on a bien vu que dans la
question des médicaments il y a la
question des médicaments matures et la
question des médicaments innovants de
manière plus générale nous souhaitons
avec cette audition pouvoir mieux
comprendre la politique de soutien à
l'investissement dans l'innovation et
l'industrie à l'Est l'industrialisation
déployée par des pays France dans le
secteur du médicament et quel est votre
doctrine en la matière avec votre double
casquette de banque mais aussi
évidemment de banque publique et quand
on parle d'investissement dans
l'innovation l'innovation existe
également dans le process de fabrication
et pas uniquement dans la parution de
molécules innovantes
pour cette audition d'une durée environ
d'une heure nous vous laisserons tout
d'abord la parole pour un propos général
de 10 minutes j'insiste sur le cadre
de 10 minutes puis madame Laurence
cohelle rapporteur de notre commission
dans lequel vous posera des questions
plus précises nous vous demanderons
également de bien vouloir nous retourner
les réponses écrites en complément de
cette audition sur la base du
questionnaire qui vous sera transmis à
son issue et je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles 434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je vous
invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur Dufour
madame Raymond
monsieur marin lamellé je vous remercie
et vous avez la parole 10 minutes
alors on s'était vu sur un autre sujet
et cette occasion
on avait commencé à évoqué celui-ci d'où
ma présence peut-être aujourd'hui donc
au fond de tableau évidemment le
diagnostic est posé je pense qu'il fait
qu'on s'insus sur le fait que
la généralisation du passage au
générique c'est traduit par des
délocalisations massives de production
principale actifs en Inde et en Chine
pour à peu près 80% des principes actifs
tout ceci a permis des baisses de prix
extraordinairement importantes dont on
peut se réjouir d'une certaine manière
car elles ont sans doute pu contribuer à
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
après tout mais elles ont contribué
aussi à des industrialiser le pays
très clairement alors le covid arrive
nous sommes en mars 2020 et le plan de
relance
arrive quant à lui nous sommes en
septembre 2020
et très vite donc on identifie les
conséquences
on va dire stratégique souveraine et
géopolitique dramatique qui n'avait pas
du tout été anticipé
du choix massif en faveur des génériques
dans les années 90 2000 2010
d'ailleurs personne n'avait réellement
anticipé les conséquences
géopolitiques de la dépendance
incroyable de l'Europe à la Chine et à
l'Inde sur ces fameux principes actifs
essentiels pour nos familles
dépendance qui est toujours là commence
donc une réflexion sur la relation la
souveraineté la relocalisation et parmi
tous les appels à projets qui sont
instruits documentés gérés par BPI
France il y en a un qui est celui qui
porte le doux de capacités building je
ne sais pas vous dire pourquoi
l'État nous a demandé d'utiliser un
anglicisme toujours est-il que des
volumes subventionnés significatifs sont
déployés pour pouvoir relocaliser de la
production principale
dans le même temps BPI France est invité
à ce pencher sur des investissements
capital donc quelques grands actifs qui
sont séquences nous rentrons au capital
de séquence et Europe pays nous
commençons à travailler à notre entrée
au capital d'euro API nous sommes Paris
au capital de ETI farm
et nous sommes en dette
chez laboratoire d'elbert
dont nous avions parlé la dernière fois
madame la sénatrice voilà
nous avons déployé au total à peu près
900 millions
d'aide à la relocalisation et à la
reconstruction de capacité mais ceci n'a
pas résolu le problème fondamental qui
est le problème des prix
problème qui se concentre sur deux
acronymes qui sont le CEPS et uni achat
et nous n'y pouvons rien nous payer
France évidemment donc je vais pas
commenter à l'infini ceci juste pour
dire que nous sommes centrés sur
l'entrepreneur et donc la voie de
l'entrepreneur c'est celle qui circulent
dans nos veines l'entrepreneur nous dit
que les prix du CEPS sont en dessous des
coûts de production parfois assez
souvent même y compris parfois même des
prix de production chinois ça peut
arriver donc et ce sont les plus bas
d'Europe quoi qu'il arrive cela tout le
monde le sait et l'entrepreneur nous dit
également que une nuit achat commence à
accepter les discussions intelligentes
plus réelles sur des réservations de
capacité
mais que
les procédures les cahiers des charges
tout l'encadrement juridique
sont incroyablement lourdes
par rapport à d'autres pays européens
à partir de là
on fait comme tout le monde le constat
de la pénurie médicament on va comme
tout le monde nous avons nos enfants
nous avons nos parents dans les
pharmacies françaises qui nous
expliquent les médicaments sont pas
disponibles où sont ces médicaments
question ouverte mais il est pas
totalement exclu que il soit vendus dans
des pays européens où les prix sont plus
élevés en tout cas c'est ce que disent
les officines
très clairement alors
BPI français ce qu'on fait au-delà de ce
que je viens d'indiquer on finance très
fortement
la recherche médicale finalement
en biotechnologie avec nos fonds de
biotech avec les fonds privés de biotech
que nous finançons ça c'est du capital
donc nous avons notre fond Ino bio nous
avons
2021 de grands fonds privés français qui
dépendent beaucoup de nous pour leur
financement et qui sortent des molécules
mais là on est sur les traitements
avancés donc les traitements très
onéreux donc on a une action principale
sur une alternative sur le monde du
générique ça c'est c'est une action dite
industrielle j'ai cité les entreprises
de capital et que nous sommes et puis
nous avons une action start-up qui est
une action de financement de
l'innovation en santé finalement voilà
pour par ailleurs en santé nous sommes
actionnaires aussi de de réseau de
pharmacie nous sommes actions de La
Fayette nous sommes actionnaires de le
réseau de clinique donc on a une action
santé qui est assez holistique et qui
nous sommes actions doctolib avec 10% du
capital de doctolib on a une population
vraiment transverse aussi bien sur la
santé digitale sur la prévention sur les
principes actifs les 10 sur le curatif
et sur le préventif donc nos équipes
santé elles sont soit en fonds propres
soit en subvention dans l'organisation
dirigée par Sophie Raymond que je suis
content de présenter à la présentation
nationale car Sophie et dans les équipes
de BEP France celles qui pilotent
l'ensemble des appels à projets de
France 2030
elle a pu montrer dans les années 2020
plan de relance 21 22
et début 23 France 2030 la capacité de
BP France à monter en puissance sur des
volumétries de dossiers honnêtement
gigantesques qu'on n'avait jamais traité
je t'en parle de au total accumulé de
dizaines de milliers de dossiers
complexes qui ont été instruits par nos
ingénieurs qui sont dans la direction de
Sophie donc chez Sophie il y a une
verticale santé
dirigé par vos alliés Maurice et qui
instruit
toute cet ensemble alors je pense que
j'ai fait maintenant j'ai fait j'ai pas
familier alors n'ayant pas fait mes 10
minutes
n'ayons pas familier minutes je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres
puisque dans les questions que vous nous
avez transmis vous parlez de
l'implication soutenue de PP France dans
le financement de l'innovation en santé
donc les chiffres sont les suivants je
vous en donne trois 2020 272 millions
2021 plan de relance 1160 un milliards
et 2022 540 millions donc quand on
enlève le plan de relance
en fait
la croissance est continue donc nous
sommes opérateurs fondamental du Plan
Santé 2030 à l'intérieur de France 2030
annoncé par le président de la
République
travaillons très bien avec l'agence
innovation en santé les pays France
avait proposé la création de l'agence
innovation santé historiquement c'était
au printemps de
on avait fait un grand événement dans
lequel on disait qu'il fallait
absolument qu'il y ait une agence qui
qui fasse que les gens se parlent en
réalité non pas une agence qui finance
puisque c'est nous qui finançons mais
une agence qui crée du consensus au
moins sur les diagnostics donc c'est
l'agence innovation santé qui est
maintenant des facto l'équipe santé de
la rue de Babylone du SGPI
donc ça c'est les montants de
subventions
et puis alors en capital nous avons
investi en 2020 sans 30 millions en
capital risque
donc sérénie selectis des BV etc toutes
les start-up de la bibliothèque
française 2021 150 millions et 2022 250
millions pourquoi s'il y a un saut
majeur c'est qu'on a mis un gros ticket
dans le doctolib en 2022 on a mis 100
millions d'euros doctolib
ce qui nous donne une présence
importante
au capital 10% et une présence au
conseil d'administration de cette
entreprise qui est devenue stratégique
pour la France
voilà ça c'est la partie capitale risque
à laquelle s'ajoute nos investissements
capital développement donc séquences je
vais dire vous avez visité l'usine de
Roussillon europapi
Europe pays exactement
CDM Lavoisier et tiffarm et puis je l'ai
dit les pharmacies Lafayette etif arme
et yph
voilà et puis sinon ce que nous faisons
qui est très important pour nous c'est
du conseil donc on a des missions de
conseil aux entrepreneurs que ce soit
des startupers ou des PME
et nous avons même créé une petite école
qui s'appelle l'accélérateur
technologie de santé
vous savez nous avons créé 150
accélérateurs on avait parlé dans toutes
les verticales textiles métallurgie etc
donc il y a un accélérateur
technologique de santé dans lequel il y
a une promotion de 20 entrepreneurs qui
pendant deux ans travaillent ensemble
et sur l'amélioration de la performance
de leurs entreprises voilà
merci beaucoup je vais donc tout de
suite passer de la parole à Laurence
Cohen rapporteur pour une première salle
de questions
oui merci pour ce propos la miner donc
ça va me permettre effectivement de vous
poser des questions
un peu plus précises pour avoir plus
plus d'éléments tout d'abord nous avons
l'impression au cours des nombreuses
auditions que nous avons mené que les
aides publiques sont particulièrement
généreuses en matière pharmaceutique
mais que malheureusement les retours sur
investissement pour les patientes et les
patients français qui sont confrontés
comme vous l'avez souligné ou pénuries
et aussi au manque d'accès au traitement
innovant ne sont pas à la hauteur alors
le modèle économique du médicament
surtout en ce qui concerne les
médicaments innovants est-ce qu'il
serait structurellement déficitaire sans
l'intervention de la puissance publique
ou bien sommes-nous dans un cas typique
de nationalisation des pertes mais de
privatisation des
c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question concerne le fait
que
des pays France cite le chiffre si je ne
me suis pas trompé de 800 millions
d'euros d'investissement étrangers
et c'est dans l'une des publications
donc où est annoncé ça a été annoncé par
l'industrie pharmaceutique à l'occasion
du sommet chose France 2022 quelle part
de cet investissement étranger en France
est dirigé vers les activités recherche
et développement et qu'elle part vers
des activités de production et est-ce
qu'il existe toujours un déséquilibre on
va dire spécifique à la France qui
accueille donc une grande partie de la
recherche et du développement mais non
récolte que très peu les fruits en
termes de production sur le territoire
ma troisième question concerne le fait
que vous avez évoqué dans votre propos
liminaire un certain nombre de projets
effectivement que BPI France
finance mais je voudrais avoir plus de
précision sur les projets qui sont
privilégiés en fait et sur quels
critères est-ce que par exemple parmi
les critères que vous retenez et bien
c'est un ancrage durable de la
production en France est-ce que vous
prenez en compte les risques qui sont
liés à l'investissement à la
compétitivité etc enfin il y a plusieurs
critères
quels sont ceux que vous vous prenez
vous prenez en compte et évidemment il y
a un critère important c'est
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins on
pourrait dire aussi
l'intérêt thérapeutique pour la santé
publique est-ce que c'est un critère qui
est pris également compte donc par BPI
France dans ces choix d'investissement
ou de
soutien et
sur quelle donnée finalement vous vous
appuyez pour évaluer ses choix et quand
vous soutenez tel ou tel projet est-ce
que vous avez connaissance de manière
précise des autres aides publiques qui
ont été perçues sur ces mêmes projets
ma quatrième question c'est toujours sur
les projets vous l'avez d'ailleurs
souligné vous êtes intervenu vous avez
soutenu effectivement
le projet
en 2021 de ces 15 pour 94 millions je
crois
de soutien de soutien financier donc
est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu nous
nous décrire les autres projets de cet
ordre là que vous avez pu que vous avez
pu soutenir
vous avez également
au niveau du plan innovation santé 2030
vous avez pu bénéficier en tout cas
c'est ce que prévoit le gouvernement une
mobilisation de deux milliards d'euros
supplémentaires est-ce que ce sont des
fonds qui vont abonder des dispositifs
d'aide existants ou est-ce que ça va
créer de nouveaux positifs et comment
seront-ils utilisés
ma sixième question c'est concernant les
relocalisations de manière peut-être un
peu plus pointue donc il y a
effectivement les fonds que vous pouvez
que vous pouvez donc apporter j'ai parlé
de ces 15 on est allé avec la présidente
sur place pour rencontrer l'équipe et
voir l'usine qui va bientôt sortir
sortir de terre mais quand on veut
relocaliser en France on mobilise aussi
pas toutes les collectivités qui sont
autour or au cours des années
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
c'est un point de vue que j'ai moi c'est
qu'on a supprimé les impôts de
production donc on a diminué les
ressources des collectivités dans ce
cadre-là est-ce que vous pensez que les
collectivités vont pouvoir aider à la
relocalisation et puis j'ai une toute
dernière question j'avais dit que
c'était la dernière mais c'est vous qui
finalement dans votre proposition
introductive m'avait fait réagir et
c'est effectivement important dans une
commission dans une commission d'enquête
j'avoue que que par rapport à la mission
de BPI France en tout cas ce que j'en
avais perçu je suis étonnée que vous
ayez pu aider
doctolib pour 100 millions d'euros je ne
vois pas en quoi ça
répond à la mission que vous avez et
deuxièmement je ne pense pas que d'auto
libre avait besoin de ce financement
particulier à mon avis ils ont d'autres
sources de financement
même si la dernière question est en
parallèle de la question sur les
pénuries
je vous remercie par avance de vos
réponses mais c'est vrai que je ne vous
aurais pas posé cette question si vous
ne vous aviez pas informé de cet apport
voilà je vous laisserai répondre très
bien bon je vais peut-être commencer par
la dernière comme ça on va aller
non je suis tout à fait
donc nous n'avons pas donné de
subventions à doctolib nous investissons
de son propriétaire
investi donc nous avons nous sommes
propriétaires de doctolib vous êtes
propriétaire doctolib la nation est
propriétaire de cette partie là nous
avons 10% du capital comme nous avons du
capital dans aujourd'hui mille
entreprises françaises en direct 1000
comment
oui oui docteur
simplement c'est une infrastructure
fondamentale maintenant et donc on n'a
pas du tout envie que doctolib soit
racheté par un groupe indien ou
américain et donc c'est notre mission
souveraine d'ancrage français
qui joue en la matière simplement comme
ce sont les entreprises magnifiques
évidemment c'est une c'est un
investissement capital qui est
significatif mais qui n'est pas à risque
je vous rassure
c'est exactement la même catégorie
d'investissement que le fait pour nous
d'avoir 7% du capital de stellantise 13
% du capitalistes
et 10% du capital d'orange c'est notre
mission font souverain
alors ensuite question numéro 1
nationalisation des pertes et
privatisation des profits je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire ça
au fond ça c'est une manière de voir qui
pourrait s'appliquer à la totalité du
financement d'innovation il n'y a pas de
financement d'innovation sans argent
public nulle part ça n'existe pas nous
sommes sur un modèle qui est un modèle
qui est assez normatif maintenant qu'on
retrouve partout en Europe du Nord qu'on
retrouve en Israël qu'on retrouve aux
États-Unis très fortement en
Grande-Bretagne
donc c'est un modèle dans lequel il y a
une un partage de la prise de risque sur
l'innovation en santé entre la puissance
publique et
les capitaux privés alors ça prend la
forme de subventions pour les
subventions elles sont accordées une
fois qu'elles sont accordées elles le
sont définitivement
elles sont sous conditions de présence
en France
ça prend la forme d'avance remboursable
donc là s'il y a un succès l'avance est
remboursé et puis ça prend la forme de
capital et si c'est un succès le capital
vaut beaucoup d'argent même
potentiellement et ça c'est le
portefeuille de c'est le portefeuille de
BPI France et c'est le portefeuille des
fonds privés financés par BPI France
l'innovation santé elle est
effectivement en courbanji assez
profonde donc les les pertes initiales
les risques pris sont très importants
c'est une des classes d'actifs qui est à
la fois l'une des plus risquées
historiquement dans le capital risque
depuis le milieu des années 90 et la
plus profitable c'est à dire que le
succès une fois sur dix est un
gigantesque succès quand on regarde
depuis 1995 jusqu'à aujourd'hui toutes
les cordes de performance des fonds de
capital risque français et même
européens
qu'est-ce qu'elle le plus profitable la
biotech plus que le vainqueur capital
digital
au fond
[Musique]
les fonds de biotech français Parisiens
ont dégagé des performances en retour
sur investissement mais c'est le cas
également aux États-Unis supérieur à la
moyenne des performances de la des fonds
de Digital californien
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'on met du
capital c'est que c'est une manière de
brancher une pompe sur la création de
valeur on a financé en subventions on a
pris les risques sur les avances
remboursables on branche une pompe en
création de valeur sur le capital et si
ça marche c'est quand même un actif
important qu'on peut ensuite revendre et
sur lequel on génère des plus-values
très significatives quand réinjectent
ensuite dans le financement d'innovation
donc c'est un système qui est assez bas
assez bien bouclé au fond je rappelle
quand même que BPI France on gère 54
milliards d'euros de fonds propres
investi dans les entreprises
et en génère chaque année entre 1
milliard et demi et deux milliards
d'euros de résultat net un milliard et
demi et 2 milliards d'euros de résultats
nets par an qui viennent essentiellement
de nos investissements fonds propres
alors ensuite les investissements
étrangers 800 millions quelle part en
recherche développement qu'elle part en
production honnêtement je ne sais pas
répondre à la question
qu'il faudrait poser probablement
à business France
est-ce qu'il y aura un déséquilibre
spécifique en France entre la richesse
développement et la production
historiquement oui dans ce secteur comme
dans toutes les verticales de
l'industrie grâce au crédits pour
recherche on a gardé la recherche et on
a laissé partir les usines ça c'est
incontestable il y a un chiffre que je
pense
qualifie la spécifité française c'est le
pourcent c'est le rapport entre le
nombre de salariés de l'industrie
des entreprises françaises à l'étranger
par rapport aux salariés restés en
France vous prenez l'entreprise
industriels françaises la journée
salariale étrangers
à l'étranger qu'en France
parce qu'en fait elles ont mis toutes
leurs unités pendant les années 2000 à
l'étranger
en Allemagne c'est un virgule 7 en
Italie c'est 1,5 en Espagne c'est un
voilà donc la France est le pays qui a
le plus délocalisé dans ces années là
qui sont les années de la Grande des
industrialisation des années de ce que
j'ai appelé le drame
alors il y a plein de raisons pourra
revenir sur le sujet mais mais dans
aucun particulier du secteur de la santé
il y a en effet
la montée en puissance massive des
génériques
indiens et
chinois
alors les critères donc
des catégories d'actions qui sont très
différentes les unes des autres
quand on fait un prêt au laboratoire
Gaétan par exemple bon on fait un prêt
bancaire c'est les critères bancaires
quand on fait une avance remboursable à
séquence sur la relocalisation de la
fabrication du principe actif du
paracétamol là l'avant c'est les
remboursable si sur une durée les
détails vous seront donnés par Sophie
mais raisonnable
la production de principes actifs à
Roussillon
éprouvé comme profitable
à ce moment-là on procède au
remboursement de l'avance la subvention
la subvention elle est conditionnée
au contrat moral qui est que on est là
pour relocaliser donc il faut que les
machines ne bougent plus que l'usine
soit pas vidée pour être transférée
dans un autre pays
et ce sont ceux-là les conditions mais
il est vrai que il n'y a pas comme
condition le fait que les médicaments
produits par l'usine de Roussillon iront
d'abord dans les pharmacies françaises
cette condition n'est pas posée donc on
ne sait pas
où va la production des usines que nous
avons relocalisées quand on relocalise
c'est pour qu'il y ait un tissu
industriel français et pour que les
emplois en France
il n'a pas été prévu à ce stade
que relocalisé pour alimenter d'abord
les pharmacies françaises puisque le cas
de figure de la pénurie de paracétamol
dans les pharmacies françaises quand on
a à la demande de l'État puisque ça
n'est pas nous qui fixons toutes ces
conditions c'est l'état
imaginez que il puisse y avoir une
pénurie de l'aspirine
ou soit bien précis c'est pas un
objectif de santé publique c'est un
objectif de réindustrialisation
c'est un objectif de souveraineté dans
la production c'est à dire qu'en cas de
crise on garde toute la production pour
nous ça c'est sûr dans des cas
exceptionnels on garde mais ça ça
suppose
on garde la production non c'est pas
écrit comme ça mais mais
ce qu'on peut se dire c'est que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne
s'il y a une crise terrible tout d'un
coup l'État a les moyens l'État a les
moyens réglementaires de dire
on garde les médicaments pour la
population française mais c'est pas
prévu dans la contractualisation
c'est pas prévu dans la
contractualisation
alors séquence donc séquence
bénéficié effectivement de 58 millions
d'euros de subventions et 40 millions
d'euros d'avance remboursable et
donc vous savez vous savez tout puisque
vous y allez vous avez une présentation
je pense très très approfondie de
l'actif je pense que c'est un sujet de
fierté finalement d'avoir réussi à faire
ça bien sûr on n'aurait jamais pu le
faire s'il y avait pas eu en effet cette
contribution publique
qui pourra d'ailleurs être remboursé par
le fait que nous sommes désormais
actionnaires
et que dans la durée la valeur de cette
actif va monter donc les choses se
compensent
par ailleurs on a étant au conseil
d'administration de séquence la
possibilité là aussi de participer à la
jeunesse stratégique de consolidation
européenne sur la production de
principes actifs
puisqu'une des faiblesses de l'Europe
c'est que elle n'est pas assez
concentrée sur la production des
principes actifs elle a trop de petits
groupes trop de petits groupes
donc il y aura forcément des
consolidations
et nous serons à la table de discussion
quand tu auras assez grandes
consolidation donc je pense que
honnêtement c'est bien fait du point de
vue d'intervention publique
je dis pas parce que c'est nous qui
sommes à la manœuvre tout n'a pas été
pensé par nous les appels à
manifestation d'intérêt sont venus
d'ailleurs on nous les a confié mais au
total pour un peu de distance de
l'avance remboursable de la subvention
du crédit pour cherche du capital pour
participer au destin stratégique de
l'entreprise
des petits coups de pouce sur les prix
aussi au CEPS pour que le paracétamol
français soit quand même un minimum
compétitif
ça tient la route ça n'a pas toujours
tenu la route comme ça on a eu le cas de
kerlid qui est une entreprise qui fait
partie de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt construction de capacité et
qui est relide
en dépit de la subvention qu'elle a reçu
pour la localiser la production
principale n'a pas tenu dans la durée
n'était pas compétitive en dépit de la
sub en dépit des avances remboursables
ça n'a pas marché elle restait trop cher
par rapport aux Indiens donc ça veut
dire que
si on veut réussir face aux Indiens et
aux Chinois il faut quand même mettre
pas mal d'argent public
et il faut ensuite structurer des
plateformes industrielles qui soient
réellement compétitives le sujet c'est
la compétitivité
alors bon ça
ça pointe ensuite évidemment sur la
politique de fixation des prix du CEPS
mais ça c'est tout à fait hors du mandat
de pays France
alors le plan santé 2030 les deux
milliards donc ça fait partie des 54
milliards
ce sont les appels à manifestation
d'intérêt et les appels d'offres santé
du plan France 2030
au fond dans France 2030 on a baptisé on
a donné une marque on a peint une
verticale santé on l'a appelé santé 2030
donc c'est pas 2 milliards de plus dans
ces deux milliards il y avait déjà de
l'argent qui était prévu par le pays A4
il y a pas tellement plus que ce qu'il y
avait déjà été prévu ici à la fois la
partie structurelle
effectivement à la fois la partie
structurelle c'est-à-dire que on finance
de la santé dans tous nos dispositifs
d'aide
non thématiques j'allais dire et puis
après il y a les dispositifs portés par
les stratégies de maladies infectieuses
émergentes la dispositif de de
dispositifs médicaux le plan concernant
la bioproduction et le
et voilà et qui sont les stratégies
verticales de France 2030 donc
ce qu'il y a comme
vous avez dit il y a rien de nouveau en
fait en fonction par rapport au pays A4
en fait c'est très important de
comprendre que la vision de mes pays
France qu'on a toujours poussé
c'est que les sachants ne savent pas
tout les jurys les ne savent pas tout il
y a quantité de choses qui viennent de
l'écosystème qui n'ont pas été prévus et
qui sont probablement souvent les choses
qui vont vraiment nous surprendre ce qui
vient bottomov de l'écosystème on
appelle ça le structurel
ce qui vient Top Down c'est les
stratégies verticales de France 2030
donc le structurel c'est des avances
remboursables c'est des prêts à taux
zéro c'est des préalamorçage des prêts
l'innovation c'est du financement de
cofinancement de business angels etc
c'est bon c'est tout le monde de
l'amorçage où nous sommes certes
sélectif mais on est surtout à l'écoute
du terrain c'est les entrepreneurs qui
savent
le monde du
des stratégies d'accélération c'est un
monde dans lequel on définit des sujets
on lance des appels à candidature et en
voir monter des dossiers très différents
voilà donc dans les deux milliards il y
a les deux grosso modo 55 ans
alors les collectivités oui la question
c'était la question même coin c'était
sur les impôts de production
les impôts de production ils sont
compensés par l'État
la promesse qui a été faite
j'en sais pas plus mais normalement les
impôts de production sont compensés non
mais le sujet il est il est quand même
majeur c'est à dire que si on s'arrête
là on ne réindustrialise pas la France
peut-être essayer d'avoir des petites
des précisions petit ou grandes
effectivement quand je vous parle de de
crédit public et
ce que je
ce sur quoi je vous interroge c'est
sur un juste équilibre or le sentiment
que l'on peut avoir c'est un
déséquilibre justement en tes faveurs du
public c'est-à-dire plus de de
d'apports publics par rapport à ce qui
est reçu en retour donc ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
quand vous parlez des
usines relocalisées et c'est très bien
vous nous avez apporté une précision de
taille c'est-à-dire que en fait c'est un
enjeu industriel et les productions de
ces de ces
usines là ne sont pas garanties comme
devant aller sur le territoire français
ça ne fait pas partie
du contrat mais moi je voudrais savoir
par rapport à ce contrat
quelles sont les garanties pour que ces
usines restent sur le territoire parce
que là elle reçoivent donc des aides des
subventions etc elle s'engage
effectivement et il y a des
investissements extrêmement importants
en termes de machines enfin bon bref
mais qu'est-ce qu'il garantit quels sont
les clauses qui nous permettent d'avoir
une sécurisation pour que dans deux ans
ça recommence pas enfin quand j'y ai
deux ans deux ans ou trois ans voilà
donc est-ce que là par rapport à ces
critères et assez garantis industriel
vous avez effectivement des exigences
avec un contrat qui va sécuriser tout ça
et du coup je suis un peu étonné parce
que quand vous donnez par exemple
le carlide
vous avez quand même il y a juste titre
enfin je remets pas en cause donner une
subvention à cette entreprise
sauf que en fait sans avoir de garanti
de la de la pérennité de ce
modèle économique puisque quelque temps
après vos subventions et bien
l'entreprise a fermé donc je suis
toujours un petit peu étonné parce que
au Sénat nous sommes la chambre des
collectivités nous avons tout et tous
souvent des mandats locaux et quand il y
a des de moins en moins tu as raison
Alain mais et mais du coup quand il y a
des subventions qui sont fournies par
les par les collectivités c'est toujours
avec critères extrêmement pointus et on
contrôle donc je suis toujours un peu
étonnée de de ce décalage quand et
notamment par rapport à carlide voilà
les précisions que je souhaiterais
entendre je vais juste compléter pour
que parce qu'on est vraiment en
commission d'enquête de concernant la
pénurie de médicaments comment à un
moment les stratégies de BPI France qui
sont pas même si s'inscrivent dans des
perspectives industrielles y compris
dans le domaine de la santé
comment un moment on peut considérer que
face à cette grave situation de pénurie
médicamenteuse qui nécessite une
politique assez assez ferme de santé
publique et forcément en lien avec la
réindustrialisation et la souveraineté
comment puisque manifestement ça fait
pas partie des sujets c'est-à-dire vos
choix sont pas forcément des choix
arbitrés du point de vue sanitaire si je
comprends
non mais c'est on essaie de comprendre
le process quand même le procès
dans ce que je veux dire c'est que
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous décidez
d'investir dans tel ou tel industrie de
fabrication de principes actifs et
est-ce que la question de la pénurie
intervient à un moment ou un autre dans
les choix que vous opérez même si
évidemment vous devez prendre en compte
le business plan et le modèle économique
de tout ça j'entends bien puisque vous
nous dites derrière que finalement il
n'y a pas de regard sur le volume
produit son usage sa destination et donc
en matière de politique de santé
publique quelque part il y a une
déconnexion entre ce qui a été choisi et
ce qui sort
bon je fais une mise au point qui je
pense paraît essentiel
et puis ils font cette opérateur de
l'État donc opérateur du ministère de la
Santé au cas particulier donc c'est le
ministère de la santé et la direction
générale des entreprises à Bercy
qui rédige l'appel
un projet
sur la base de ce qu'ils identifient
comme étant les pénuries qui doivent
être traités
c'est nous qui ensuite publions l'appel
à projet recueillons les dossiers
instruisant les dossiers et ensuite
quand il faut décider c'est une décision
collégiale entre
l'instructeur
qui n'a quasiment pas de délégation
à la différence de ce qui se passait
avant et les ministères donc les les
automobiles qui ont été choisis dans cet
appel à manifestation d'intérêts
capacité building c'est-à-dire
typiquement séquence
Panpharma vous avez tout ça toute cette
liste bon ont été choisis par l'État
non pas sur des critères de
réindustrialisation mais sur des
critères de santé
ensuite dans la documentation quand on
attribue les
critères de santé au sens où on se dit
il faut qu'on ait une usine qui sache
fabriquer ça en France quoi mais pour
autant on n'a pas mis dans la
documentation L'état ne l'a pas mis le
fait que la totalité de la production
devait aller à la population française
voilà
oui ce sera peut-être le cas à l'avenir
ça nous échappe ça mais ce n'est pas le
cas on est d'accord
voilà donc c'est pas il s'agit pas
simplement de réindustrialiser la France
là il s'agissait très clairement plan de
relance vous souvenez de l'ambiance de
de réassurer une souveraineté de
production de principes essentiels en
France
alors donc Madame Cohen sur carlide
non mais l'économie malheureusement elle
n'est pas administrée totalement ou
alors aucun particulier il se trouve
qu'elle l'est beaucoup mais mais les
choses évoluent c'est à dire que carlide
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait avec nos 5
millions de subventions modernisation de
l'outil de production de carlide afin de
répondre à la pérennisation et à
l'augmentation de la capacité de
production française de médicaments
critiques c'est ses poches de
paracétamol bien malgré la baisse du
coût de production
quand même beaucoup baissé le coup de
production grâce à une ligne
complètement automatisée permettant
diminuer le prix de revient des poches
par un effet volume cela n'a pas suffi
car les prix des appels d'offres des
centrales d'achat ont encore baissé
c'est à dire que vous faites votre
business plan
et paf les prix des centrales d'achat
recommence à baisser voilà c'est ça qui
s'est passé l'augmentation forte des
coûts de l'énergie c'était pas prévu et
des matières premières en partie dues à
la crise ukrainienne a accéléré le
problème de Kerline voilà
et donc quelqu'un cherche à reprendre le
site aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il faut
reprendre le site très clairement
voilà pour le reste c'est une question
très directe donc si si finalement dans
les appels dans les appels d'offres
hospitalier la dimension de favorisant
favorisant c'est pas ça mais dans les
critères des éléments liés à la
souveraineté qui a amené j'allais dire
une pondération plus favorable dans le
choix uniquement le choix du prix
par les grands acheteurs communis achats
est-ce que cela aurait permis de le
maintien de l'usine c'est une question
très alors
c'est le premier argument que vous
mettez en avant et on a bien compris
quand même quelque part le
fonctionnement en silo voilà de cette
question du médicament surtout toute la
chaîne de valeur tous ces intervenants
la multiplicité des acteurs fait que on
voit bien que faute d'avoir un regard
unique ou au moins un pilotage
ça fait finalement des compétitifs
publics qui sont mises en échec par
d'autres politiques publiques
donc là dessus dans les
cahiers des charges d'achat de uniasha
il y a déjà des clauses on va dire de
localisation
il est déjà prévu que vous pouvez ne
pas tenir compte simplement du prix sauf
que honnêtement c'est pas piqué
je crois que certains entrepreneurs vous
l'ont dit
il faudrait il faudrait donc donner un
coup de pouce pour permettre à
la santé au management de l'ensemble de
ces agences
de hiérarchiser finalement les priorités
est-ce que c'est la localisation est-ce
que c'est seulement le prix sachant que
on joue sur honnêtement des Pouilles on
est sur des volumes très élevés donc on
parle de pouillame de prix
les principes actifs sur le paracétamol
c'est 4% du coût de la boîte 4% donc
c'est quelques centimes par boîte
et donc ce dont on a besoin pour pouvoir
financer des lignes de production c'est
0, quelque chose centime
par boîte
on n'est pas en train de dire qu'il faut
10 euros de plus par boîte c'est c'est
des énormes volumes
sur quelque chose qui est totalement
comme on l'utiliser
c'est à dire que c'est un c'est une
commodité
bien merci beaucoup pour ces éléments
très voilà très éclairant est-ce que
vous avez des questions chers collègues
complémentaires je pense que ça a permis
de regarder un peu comment les
choses fonctionnaient merci beaucoup
merci
on fera parvenir